[MUSIC]
I grew up in the suburbs of Chicago,
which was a wonderful liberal bubble.
Then I moved to Tennessee for college.
After that, I moved to Texas for
my first job.
I met people who grew up shooting
guns with their grandfathers.
People who had strong religious
convictions about abortion and
gay marriage.
If I'm being totally honest,
the whole thing stressed me out.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I knew we disagreed about so
many things, but
I didn't want to bring them up.
I was worried I might offend someone,
that I might get labeled as intense.
Or that I might end up in one
of those politically correct,
agree to disagree situations
that everyone hates.
And I don't think I'm alone.
For most of us, talking about politics
is stressful and awkward, and
if it's not it's probably because you're
only talking to people who agree with you.
So, what I want to do today is
talk about talking about politics.
Why we don't, why we should and
most importantly, how we can do it better.
So, why don't we like
talking about politics?
For one thing,
we're taught from a very young age
that the topic is just rude, right?
Just like money or religion,
I'm not supposed to know your salary,
question your belief in God,
or ask who you voted for.
And then even when we do
start to talk about politics,
we usually don't think we're
going to change anybody's mind.
It's not that often that we convince
somebody to change a really
deep seated political view.
Even more fundamentally,
when we talk about politics,
we often feel insecure and defensive.
Have you ever worried that someone
might think you're uninformed?
That you might get judge for
a controversial opinion?
Research shows that when people are shown
information that contradicts their
political views, the parts of their brain
that light up are those associated with
personal identity,
emotion, threat response.
In other words, we feel insecure and
defensive because we're literally wired
to view attacks on our political
beliefs as attacks on ourselves.
So we're conditioned to
believe the topic is rude,
we don't think we're going to
change anybody's mind.
And we feel insecure and defensive.
So then why should we talk about politics,
isn't it easier to just leave
it to the talking heads on CNN.
I actually think that talking about
politics sharpens our thinking.
When I spoke to my conservative friends in
Tennessee and Texas, I realized that a lot
of things I think the government should
do actually cost a whole lot of money.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Sharing, I believe,
helps us challenge, crystallize,
reassess what we believe.
We start recognizing trade-offs and
our views become more nuanced.
And hey, if anyone is going to change your
mind about something, it's probably not
going to be Anderson Cooper, despite
that persuasive jawline I wish I had.
>> [LAUGH]
>> It's going to be your friends,
neighbors, coworkers,
classmates, people you trust and that you
can have an actual conversation with.
Even more importantly though,
talking about politics helps us
share ourselves with the world.
We aren't born with any
set of political beliefs.
The issues we care most about come
from out most meaningful experiences.
For me, I think about the day a close
friend in high school came out to me.
That was the day that gay
rights became personal.
I think about the incredible public school
teachers who are literally the reason I am
at Stanford today, Why I care so
much about investing in public education.
I think about my parents,
who came to this country
from India with nothing in their pockets,
to give their children,
to give me a better life.
That's why I think immigrants
should be celebrated, not vilified.
This is the stuff that makes you, you.
And the real you, the you that is human
in the most beautiful and authentic and
wonderful of ways it's too valuable and
too precious to leave locked up inside.
So we need to talk about politics more and
we need to talk about politics better.
And so, here are the five most practical
things I can tell about how to do that.
First, come from a place of
curiosity not offense or defense.
I know that sounds like Tom Brady
started reading fortune cookies so,
let me give you an example.
When I was in college,
I moderated a debate between the college
Democrats in the college Republicans.
It actually went really well and so
naturally I was walking around afterwards
being like move over, Tom Brokaw,
because there is a new face at NBC.
But the woman who was organizing
the debate ran up to me furious.
She made me watch the video, when the
Democrat was speaking I was nodding and
smiling uncontrollably.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I literally looked like a bobble head.
>> When the Republican was speaking,
I just looked angry.
>> [LAUGH]
>> I was not coming from a place of
curiosity.
I was coming from a place of offense and
defense.
I just wanted my team to win and
as a result, missed out on
the opportunity to learn something.
Second, pick the right time and place.
Discussions about politics can
be really difficult when there's
an audience watching.
Whether that's a real audience
around a dinner table, or
a virtual audience on Facebook.
Try waiting for
more intimate opportunity to talk to
someone like over a cup of coffee.
As one mediation expert puts it,
don't always stand up
to those with different beliefs,
instead try sitting down with them.
Three, focus on one topic at a time.
Don't attack the entire Democratic or
Republican Party or everything the person
has believed in their entire lives.
That's when we feel most defensive and
insecure.
By focusing on one topic,
we can actually accomplish something over
the course of a single conversation.
Fourth, listen actively, use body language
that shows you're paying attention.
Ask questions, paraphrase to verify you
understand what their talking about.
Most people need to feel
like they've been heard,
before they'll listen to someone else,
or consider changing their mind.
Fifth and finally, avoid verbal attacks
and obviously don't hit anybody.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Even if we're not usually
ones to lose control, it's shocking
how quickly our language can change
when we're talking about
things we really care about.
Language that's zero-sum or
that frames things in
terms of good and
evil can kill productive dialogue.
So, let's review, come from a place of
curiosity, pick the right time and place.
Focus on one topic at a time,
listen actively, and avoid attacks.
I know that's actually a lot to remember.
I don't have a cute acronym for
you to take home and hold your gasps,
but I broke the magic rule of three.
But that's kind of the point,
of course, it's not going to be easy.
We're talking about unlearning what
we've been taught our entire lives,
rewiring a part of our brain.
And just like always,
talking about politics is sometimes going
to be stressful, awkward, you name it.
But I'll tell you something,
the conversations I had over six
years of living in the South,
have made me a better friend,
a better leader, and a better American.
So let's stop taking the easy way out,
let's embrace discomfort
and let's start talking about the things
that really matter, thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]